you
okay we're finally ready to make our
nameplate the first step is to mount the
blank to the top of the jig using the
one-quarter 28 allen cap screws these
are tightened using an l-shaped wrench
called an allen wrench and make sure to
tighten these screws very hard otherwise
the part can move during the machining
process the next thing we're going to do
is Mount the bottom of the jig into the
vise the lower left-hand corner of this
jig is our reference corner we're
mounting it on the left hand side
sticking out of the vise a little bit so
that we can use an edge detector to
determine exactly where that corner is
located the center of the nameplate is
four inches to the right and one and a
quarter inches off the corner tightly
into the house make sure you tap on it
here is an edge detector
it is a 2/10 of an inch diameter tip
that is spring-loaded and attached to a
shaft it's often called a wiggler the
idea of an edge detector is you spin it
at 1500 rpm and you approach it with the
edge of the part that you wish to detect
as you approach the edge detector at
some point the edge detector will start
to spin eccentrically
the idea is to keep approaching the edge
detector until you can detect that
specific moment when the edge of the
detector encounters the edge of the part
once you are happy with the edge
detection process it is time to zero the
Machine this is done by hitting the
yellow X button zero comes up you hit
enter and you will effectively zero the
x-axis
once the x-axis has been zeroed you must
play the same game in the y-direction
it is important to realize that if you
overshoot the edge detector it is
necessary to back out the part all the
way until it starts until the edge
detector starts spinning cool again and
then you can we approach the part and
try again once you're happy with the Y
edge detection we will also 0 the y-axis
by hitting again the yellow Y button and
entering 0 since the edge detector is
2/10 of an inch in diameter it is
necessary now to move the Machine 0.1
inches in both the x and y direction in
doing that the center of the spindle
will coincide exactly with the corner of
our jig once we have done that it is
necessary again to Riis Eero the machine
so the machine will be reserved on the
corner of the jig
does drawing that I've created the
nameplate that I wish to make notice I
have
actual coordinate information I have
coordinates of various end points and
start points of the arcs the radiuses of
the arcs are mentioned the nameplate is
going to look like that and notice that
this one large radius six inches is well
outside the actual page that the drawing
is printed on and notice that the centre
of my drawing is zero zero here is the
completed nameplate that I plan on
making and let's describe a little bit
how it's going to be made this
particular one is made out of the
plexiglass so it's clear although the
one we're going to make is going to be
made out of aluminum the first process
that we're going to do is we're going to
have the face cutter the fly cutter come
across the surface of the nameplate and
make it flat now we're not going to
program this particular part of the
assignment that is going to be something
we do at the machine right before we run
the rest of the program so for your case
let's not worry about it the next thing
that's going to happen is a 3/8 of an
inch end mill is going to come along and
it's going to start here and it's going
to go along the entire piece and it's
going to do what's called profiling
it's going to cut out the aluminum plate
in several passes until it takes on the
shape of what you saw in the drawing
previously after the profiling operation
is completed this little radii that goes
along the outside to create this nice
little edge is going to be done with a
ball end mil so a ball end mil is going
to come in at go around apart
and put that radius in there the final
process will involve the engraving using
a very small end mill we will engrave
the letters the letters of mechanical
rocks will be put in there so right now
we're going to go through 50 processing
steps required to program the machine to
make this nameplate you're a machinist
or when you're working on a part you
have the dimensions of the part not the
dimensions of where the tool needs to
cut to create that part so here is a
drawing which indicates one possible
strategy in which to profile our
nameplate the N mill would start off
here it would it's always rotating
clockwise mind you looking down at it
the n mill would start here approach the
part and then go in it will go to the
left and cut out the outside dimensions
of the nameplate and when it's finished
it will retract this when this occurs
the center of the spindle will execute
the path indicated by these dotted lines
and it will leave behind the actual
nameplate that we've designed and we've
conceived of so that it's important to
realize that all the dimensions on the
milling machine are referenced to the
center of the spindle so that when you
program when the cutting takes place if
you're using a 3/8 of an inch diameter
end mill you must offset the N mill 3/16
of an inch the radius of the end mill
away from the part that you're cutting
of course you have the dimensions of the
actual part that you wish to create it
is a very difficult and painful process
to go back and figure out what the
dimensions of a 3/16 offset are so the
machine gives you the opportunity to use
this thing called cutting radio
compensation in this particular example
we are using what's called cutting
radius compensation to the left in other
words the machine we're going to program
the parts geometry into the machine and
the machine is going to automatically
offset the tool by its radius and it's
going to offset it to the left and the
word left means that if you imagine
riding on top of the n mill it's it's
going to be moving to the left and it
gets offset to the left and that's why
they call it cutting radius left this
kind of milling is called climb milling
link strategy is to use what's called
cutting radius compensation to the right
this is also called conventional milling
now in this scenario now keep in mind
the most important thing to realize is
the tools always rotate in a clockwise
direction for cutting and that's the way
the tools are designed the flutes take
the chips up and out but you are allowed
to go to the right as well as to the
left so in this scenario the tool will
go up it will go to the right come
around and finish the profiling process
now there are certain advantages to
using climb milling and there are
certain advantages to using conventional
milling it turns out that when climb
milling the cutting tool moves a little
bit away from the part it actually gets
bent slightly away from the part and in
conventional milling the cutting tool
moves into the part
so in climb milling the part is left
ever so slightly larger than the actual
size you want and in conventional
milling it is left slightly smaller now
keep in mind this is a big cutting tool
but one we're using
maybe smaller but despite the fact that
you might think that these tools are
incredibly rigid they actually are
capable of being slightly bent during
the cutting process and there are other
issues regarding the differences between
climb and conventional milling but for
the most part another aspect of it is
the finish you get it turns out that
climb milling gives you a better finish
and decided to cut out our nameplate
using cutting radius compensation to the
left or climb milling and this decisions
been done to make a better finish the
plan is to have the tool come down here
move into the part follow the dashed
line path of the tool and then come back
to this point we're going to take four
rough passes and one final pass to
complete the cut remember with cutting
radius compensation we program the
actual parts dimensions and then the
machine will compensate for the radius
of the tool so it is essential to have
an extremely good drawing that has all
pertinent end points and start points of
arcs as well as the radiuses as well as
of course you have to know where the
center zero zero is once again we're in
the computer lab where we're using the
offline software for the analog
controller it simulates the software
exactly as it appears on the actual CNC
interface so when it first comes up you
see control software number one is what
we're going to select and once again
notice we've created this little
template that has the function keys and
we will hit f5 we are now going to hit
the f2 button for program and we're
going to hit the create button f2 and
now we're going to type in a program
name which I will call nameplate 3 when
I hit enter
mainplate three comes up on the menu
right there and we are going to then
select it with the f6 button and then
we're going to hit the edit button f4
once again and we've seen this in MDI
mode the last line is always the end of
program line as we add lines to the
program they will appear above this line
it always goes above the cursor now
since we've seen this before doing the
MDI mode I'm going to do it rather
quickly the first line of my program is
going to be the selection of units which
is the number seven button make sure the
num lock button is on the seven key
brings up once again the inches which is
what I want the plus sign toggles
between inches and millimeters I select
inches and I hit enter I'm now going to
select absolute coordinates now the way
you do that is you hit the Alt key key
and once again the absolute the plus and
minus sign goes from increment to
absolute I'm going to select absolute
and our program is already building the
first thing I want to do is grab a tool
remember the first thing we're going to
do is profile the part the tool that I'm
going to select is going to be tool
number 3 which was going to be a 3/8 of
an inch end mill I am going to type the
number 5 button is for the tool
I'm going to select number three for the
tool and if you recall from the previous
video m6 is the tool change command so
we will enter that into our program the
next thing I want to do is get it
spinning at a good rpm again the period
button on the keypad brings up the RPM
screen I'm going to enter 3000 and hit
enter I am now going to move the tool to
its entry point once again according to
the drawing this coordinate is y equals
negative one point one two five this is
the bottom of the nameplate which is
probably why equals negative one point
two five and I want to enter somewhere
below that so my entry point will be Y
negative two X zero Y negative two I am
going to rapidly move to the coordinate
now rapid is number one key
it is X 0 and y negative 2 I will come
down in the Z direction in my next move
I'm now going to hit another rapid move
which is the 1 key again and I will now
enter 0.1
I am getting ready to cut right now at
this point I could turn on the coolant
with the command m8 so again it's the M
code which is the number six key and I
could enter him if I wanted to because I
actually want to put the coolant on
manually I'm going to actually delete
that line you go to it and you hit
delete two number three is going to be a
3/8 of an inch end mill however because
I want to take some rough cuts for the
first four passes I'm going to enter a
diameter slightly larger than 3/8 of an
inch into the tool table for the first
four passes and then I'm going to enter
the correct diameter for the final pass
now I want to put a comment in the
program the way I do this is I go to the
miscellaneous f9 I then hit f2 for
comment
and up comes my comment and I'm going to
say two three three eights and mill
but 0.385 in tool table
the comment appears in the program with
an asterisk in front of it so it's going
to be a 3/8 of an inch end mill
but I'm going to enter 0.385 in the tool
table I have moved the cursor back to
the bottom line so I can continue to
enter code now we move the tool down to
0.1 inches and now we have to actually
take our first pass I'm going to make
this a line move now so instead of rapid
a line move is the number 2 key and I'm
just going to bring it down to negative
0.1 inches in the z direction and I'm
going to feed at 20 inches a minute the
first thing is going to be moving the
tool from here to here this is the
coordinate y negative one point one two
five once again I'm going to enter a
line move the number two key on the
keypad brings it up we're going to move
X zero Y negative one point one two five
and I don't have to keep entering the
feed rate but at this point we are going
to invoke the cutting radius
compensation now the plus key will
toggle you from left right to off we are
compensating to the left very important
step right there
so there it is two left our first move
is going to be an arc a clockwise arc
from this point to this final point here
it has a radius of six inches so that's
going to be the next program line to
program the arc we push the f5 key the
milling program under the milling
program there is arc f4 we push the f4
key and we are entering the arc by way
of a method in which we enter the end
point of the arc and its radius it is a
clockwise arc the endpoint is X negative
two point seven six six six the Y is
negative point four four nine one and
the radius is 6 inches the next section
of our arc is going to be this little
one from this point to that point it's
radius is 0.125 inches once again I type
the f4 key for the arc brings up the
arcing program it is once again a
clockwise arc its endpoint is negative
two point seven 905 the y coordinate is
negative point two four three four and
it's radius is 0.125
I will just show the entering of one
more line we're going to go from this
point to that point and this time the
radius is 0.3 to 1 and it is a counter
clockwise arc we hit the arc the plus
sign will let you toggle from
counterclockwise to clockwise or
clockwise the counter clockwise the
coordinate of this endpoint is negative
two point seven 905 the Y is point two
four three four and the radius is point
three two one
I've entered all the lines of code now
and I've come back to my start point now
this is an important point right now I'm
going to retract the tool back to my y-
- starting point and that's when i'm
going to cancel the cutting radius
compensation otherwise it won't actually
go back to that point
last move brought me back to the end of
the part i'm going to enter one more
line move to retract the tool to the
original place and hitting the plus sign
i'm going to go through the choices
until i get to to compensation off and
that completes my cycle i would like to
draw the program now to verify it but
before i do since i'm using cutting
radius compensation the tool table must
be correct so i will hit the f6 key and
i will notice that tool number three i
have entered the diameter of 0.385 for
tool number three the reason is is
because i want it to be a rough cut
let's just briefly go over the program
as it stands we pick inches for our
units we're using absolute dimensions we
first pick tool number three which is a
three a 10 mil but we enter point three
eight five in the tool table we get it
up to 3000 RPM we rapidly go to the
point 0 negative two then we come all
the way down to 0.1 inches above the
surface and at this point we invoke line
moves instead of rapid moves and we're
feeding at a rate of 20 we come down
negative point one and we now we enter
the part so the first line move brings
us to the Y negative one point one two
five inch part and all of these arcs are
what comprises the geometry of the
profile we wish to make the final move
is we come back out to the X 0 y
negative two and we turn off the cutting
radius compensation we now want to draw
the program and verify it we hit f2 and
we hit the display when we look at the
view that we want I'm going to take a
top view which is what I want and the
display I'm going to hit
I'm on the menu fit I'm going to hit
enter now when I do that let's look at
the the drawing that looks perfect
I've exit out of the draw part of the
program and I'm back into the editor and
I want to quickly look at these lines
now I'm going to be repeating these
lines and I just want to look at what
line I want to start repeating at line
number 9 where I bring the tool
compensation left on that's going to be
the first line I want to repeat and I'm
going to go all the way back down to
line 19 that will be the last line we're
going to repeat so we're going to add a
few lines so we can take progressively
deeper cuts into this part so I'm going
to add a new line here a line move will
be Z minus point 2 and now I'm going to
tell it to repeat the repeat button is
under the mil function f5 repeat I think
you can see it is listed under f8 repeat
and up on the screen comes the blocks
that we want to repeat we said it was
going to be line 9 through 9 line 19 and
when we enter it it will put that into
our program so basically we profile the
part we move down another tenth of an
inch into Z and then we profile it again
I've added the lines to do all the
profiling I come down a tenth of an inch
four times to a final depth of Z minus
0.4 and now I want to do something a
little bit different I want to make a
final pass
I'm going to do that is I'm going to
tell the machine to grab another tool
it's actually going to be the same tool
but I'm going to enter in the tool table
the correct diameter of the tool that
will give us our final cut let's take a
quick look at the slight changes to the
program after we make our last rough cut
which is at a depth of Z minus 0.4 we
now make a tool change to to number 6
that's going to be still the 3/8 of an
inch tool but it's going to have the
correct tool diameter listed in the tool
table it does everything that we did
before we spin it at 3000 we rapidly go
down to our entry point of X 0 and Y
negative 2 and then we finally bring it
down to our final depth of negative 0.5
and then we repeat one more time the
entire profiling and that should give us
a final cut that's just a little bit of
material being taken off we should get a
really good finish out of this I just
want to point out that so I don't get
too confused I put a comment line on
line number 27 indicating that that 3/8
end mill has the proper diameter listed
in the tool table let's draw it again to
see if we're getting the passes we want
you can see it's going to make five
passes and the last pass should have
been a final pass now we're going to
take a little look at some of the
options on the drawing menu if we go to
display the f5 key you notice one of the
choices there is window I'm going to
select window you go back up to the
drawing screen you're going to see a
little window in there a box that's
going to close up on a particular part
I'm going to look at this edge to see if
we are getting a final cut and now we
will hit enter to have it redraw now
we're just looking at the very bottom
edge those are the passes and we should
see a final cut a little bit closer it's
hard to see but you can see that final
cut was slightly in more than the other
one changing the view to isometric we
can see the outline being made the next
step is to grab tool number four which
will be the ball end mil and we'll have
it come along here to create the
scalloped edge now the way we do that is
we don't use cutting radius compensation
the actual tool the center of the tool
will be hugging the edge of the part
just like this and that's how we will
get the scalloped edge hope everybody
can see what I'm talking about okay once
again let's look at the lines of code
that have been added we are asking for
line number 34 tool change to tool
number 4 which the comment line below it
shows it as a half inch ball and mill
the m3 code is clockwise direction of
the spindle we spin it up to 3000 rpm
and then we're going to again exactly
like we did before rapidly move to zero
negative to come down to zero zero point
one above the part and then we're going
to go down another 0.05 inches and then
we're going to
start our profiling again this time it's
going to not involve cutting radius
compensation I moved back up to the
lines nine through nineteen these are
the lines that contain the geometry of
our profile I am going to copy and paste
them I want to just go over one more
time this strange way this works but you
hit the f1 key four more
you enter the mark line and then you
just mark all the lines you wish to copy
and then I hit more again I come down to
copy notice the screen says lock save
and now I move my cursor down to where I
want those lines copied to which will be
right over there I hit more one more
time and I do pace and up comes the
profile geometry and it is now on line
41 that I begin everything I'm going to
hit enter so I can do a quick bit of
editing and the only thing I want to
change is the word left to off so I'm
going to come down here again the plus
sign
ratchets through all the choices and off
is what I want and now I'm just going to
quickly look at all these lines now I
turn the cutting radius compensation off
in line 51 which you know is already is
off so I'm fine I want to verify the
program again using the draw feature I
am going to look at a top view again
this is the outside profiling being done
in five passes for rough cuts and a
final finishing pass and then the next
pass was with the ball end mil notice
that since the rating radius
compensation has been cut off the tool
has moved over the radius of the tool
and this in fact will be the edge of the
part this will actually be the edge of
the part so there we are
I've added one more a couple more lines
of code
I really want my little scalloped edge
to be 1/10 of an inch deep
now this is an aesthetic choice 0.05
looks good point 1 looks pretty good I'm
going with a tenth of an inch and it
turns out that I have to repeat lines 41
through 51 so line 53 shows the repeat
command and the one thing I am going to
warn you about with the repeat function
is if you add lines to this program now
the repeat command does not take into
account that you've added up lines so be
very careful if you add lines or edit
this program the number of the lines
that you're repeating may also have to
be changed that's something you have to
do the machine is going to do that for
you let's do one more verification using
the draw command again five passes to do
the outside profiling and now it should
be two passes with the ball end mill and
it looks good switching to the isometric
view you will see it perhaps of you a
lot of people prefer to sees isometric
sometimes and it looks good let's look
at some more lines of code I've added
now the final operation for us is the
engraving operation which is going to be
tool number five that is going to be at
1/16 of an inch ball end mil for
engraving as indicated by the comment
line 55 once again we started spinning
at clockwise direction at 4,000 rpm this
little end mill likes to spin pretty
fast otherwise it will break I am
guessing the start point of the
engraving I'm not really sure how long
the letters are going to be I'm guessing
a coordinate of negative two-y point one
as the start point for the word
mechanical I'm going to use the draw
program to check whether or not that's a
good place to begin so we'll find out in
a minute how good it guess I made now to
do engraving you go to the mill program
which is the f5 key and at that point
you then hit the more button which is
the f7 button and up comes a men
that has several choices that last
choice is in grade I'm going to move
down and select in grave now when the
engraving menu comes up this is a very
simple one to use the first thing we
enter is the text so I'm going to enter
the word mechanical there's no spell
check here if you get it wrong it will
engrave a misspelled word again my start
point I took a guess was negative two-y
point one I'm going to select the start
height that's where the tool is going to
start from point one inches above the
surface the depth is going to be
extremely small 0.01 negative 0.01 for
the depth if you go more than that in
the in one pass you will break the tool
the height of the letters is the actual
height I'm going to make point four high
inch letters now keep in mind the higher
the letters the longer the word as well
these things all go together
I'm not angling it and I'm not mirroring
it I'm going to feed at a rate of ten if
you feed much faster than that you will
also break the two okay once again I
need to verify how close to being
centered my engraving is you want the
top view for this particular one when I
hit run we're going to see the entire
program now the profiling the scalloped
edge and now the engraving as you can
see the word mechanical looks to be
slightly to the left but it's fairly
well centered so I'm just going to make
some adjustments to move it over to the
right I have to make this number more
let's say like negative one point eight
the Y look good to me again verifying
the draw program having made the
adjustment in the starting point moving
it over a little bit to the right I feel
fairly good about that that will
nice okay brought up another engraving
line so it's mechanical rocks so now I
have to type in the word rocks there is
no choice of fun the X start now rocks
is a much smaller word so perhaps the
x-coordinate is more like negative one
the Y has to be below the center line so
perhaps I'll try negative 0.6 the start
height again is the same the depth is
again the same as it was in the last one
negative oh one the height of the
letters is point four of course you
could change it if you want the feed
rate is important to be 10 again to
verify it with the draw command push the
Run button and we'll see how close to
being centered the word rocks is now you
can see rocks is fairly well centered
but it really should be moved over a
little bit to the right having made some
adjustments let's just see how it looks
everything looks good okay let's review
very quickly the program we just wrote
the first line we select our units to be
inches our second line we are using
absolute dimensions we select tool three
the first thing is a tool change command
m6 this is a 3/8 inch end mill whose
diameter has been entered as point three
eight five a little bit bigger so that
these can the cutting radius
compensation retracts the tool a little
bit further away from the part I had
left out the m3 code before for
clockwise rotations so I just put that
in so we have clockwise rotation the RPM
is three thousand and we wrap it down to
our start point we then come down zi-
0.1 at a feed rate of twenty and we do
all of our geometry we after we do our
profiling we drop down another tenth of
an inch each time since it's absolute
coordinates Z's going to get incremented
to negative point two and we keep
repeating it then negative 0.3 we repeat
the profile negative point four etc to
do the final pass we change tools now
we're not really going to have to change
any tools but this is just so that the
tool table enters the correct diameter
of the tool for our final pass we come
down we make our final pass at negative
0.5 inches and we will if can finish the
profiling we then switch to our ball end
mil tool number for our ball end mil
makes the exact same geometry with the
cutting radius compensation turned off
with cutting radius compensation turned
off as shown on line 42 the center of
the spindle hugs the exact edge of the
part so we'll end up with a nice
scalloped edge we do that with two
passes one at z- oh five and then the
last one at z negative 0.1 and now we
switch to the 1/16 of an inch ball and
mel for engraving and we simply bring up
the engraving algorithm so the program
is quite simple and we're ready to run
it let me just say one thing that's
worth mentioning I had left out
this line here in the program the m3
code to turn the spindle on clockwise
when I added that line it shifted every
line down one and believe it or not I
had to go in now and change all of these
repeat lines which used to be nine
through nineteen they all became
different now they're 10 through 20 and
then my final ball and mill repeat line
also changed it was 41 to 51 it became
42 to 52 so unfortunately this is a
disadvantage of using repeat commands
but just be aware of it if you add lines
of code after you use a repeat command
you better change things